Best Performance By An Actor
And the International Emmy for Best Performance by An Actor goes to Haluk Bilginer.
Thank you.
This is a great honor and my thanks to the Academy for this precious award.
Am I allowed to invite the team, the great team that made this possible onto the stage, please?
Kerem Catay, Onur Saylak, Hakan Gunday.
I share this award with these wonderful people.
It was a great pleasure to work with them.
And our series "Persona" is about justice and amnesia,...
...but not amnesia of an individual but more dangerously and harmfully amnesia of the society.
Therefore, please make sure the society you live in does not suffer from amnesia.
If I may, I'd like to dedicate this award to my little daughter, Nazli Bilginer,...
...in the hope that one day, she may choose acting as a profession.
Thank you very much.